bonjour aujourd'hui dans notre émission
consacrée au dispositif du conseil
général je reçois le GIP SAP le
groupement d'intérêts publics pour les
services à la personne le gpsap la
maison de l'aide à la personne a pour
rôle à la prise en compte de l'ensemble
des problématiques liées au secteur des
services à la personne on estime entre
48 000 et 60000 le nombre des aidants
dans notre île il faut aussi préciser
qu'il s'agit en majorité de femmes donc
tout naturellement autour de cette table
aujourd'hui on reçoit l'une d'entre
elles Madame Jacqueline Boulard bonjour
bonjour pour nous accompagner tout au
long de cette émission Stéphanie Vergos
coordonnatrice de la politique des
aidants familiaux gpsap bonjour
Stéphanie alors c'est d'ailleurs avec
vous que nous allons commencer cet
échange la maison de l'aide à la
personne a mis en place un dispositif en
faveur des couples et dans aidés qui
comprend quatre volets et qui permet aux
aidants de prendre un peu plus de temps
pour eux et de souffler un peu est-ce
que vous pouvez nous détailler si ces
quatre volets donc le dispositif rippier
repos donc contient donc 4 volets le
volet 1 la bourse odeur donc il s'agit
d'un remplacement donc de ponctuel de
les dents par un professionnel qualifié
donc à domicile vous avez le volet 2 le
séjour en terre donc qui permet aux
aidants de bénéficier de quelques jours
de répit au village corail à
Saint-Gilles-les-Bains et de bénéficier
de prestations de bien-être au terme de
syllaos le volet 3 il s'agit de la
maison d'accueil des aidants familiaux
donc plus communément appelé la case
grandir et qui se situe à l'entre-deux
et qui a récemment ouvert donc ses
portes en octobre de cette année le
volet 4 donc le café des aidants et la
ronde de coeur donc ce sont des lieux
des moments dédiés à des groupes de
paroles et des gens de d'échanges entre
aidants et professionnel
c'est au chaudron que tous les soirs
Jacqueline vient chercher Martine qui
est accueilli en institut spécialisé
pour la journée ce soir Jacqueline prend
également Jean-Marie avec elle la mère
de ce dernier est actuellement
hospitalisée
après quelques minutes de route nous
voilà arrivés à la Bretagne c'est dans
cette maison que vit Martine depuis
maintenant 42 ans aujourd'hui les petits
enfants c'est-à-dire les nièces et ne
veut de Martine sont chez leurs
grands-parents Benoît le tout petit a
fait un dessin pour sa tata
est une personne très entourée par toute
la famille pour ses parents la naissance
l'adolescence est maintenant la vie
d'adulte de Martine a pu se faire grâce
à l'amour des siens
avec la famille comme je vous ai dit on
se réunit souvent donc voilà on s'était
réuni ce jour-là et ça c'était un beau
souvenir qu'on garde un accompagnement
solidaire mais avant tout un dévouement
de la mer mais également du père qui
entretient un lien très particulier avec
sa fille c'est une relation
une vie différente qui nécessite un
double engagement c'est pour permettre à
ces familles de souffler un peu que le
département a mis en place le dispositif
répit repos une parenthèse après 42 ans
passés à s'occuper de leur fille en
situation de handicap
Jacqueline vous vous êtes une idée de
famil vous occupez de votre fille
pouvez-vous nous raconter votre
quotidien comment ça se passe tous les
jours depuis que vous avez appris le
handicap de votre fille alors je peux
vous dire que ça dure depuis 42 ans bon
elle est née avec ce handicap on va pas
chercher les causes elle est là
maintenant et depuis 42 ans c'est tous
les jours qu'il faut s'occuper d'elle
vous savez quand on a un enfant porteur
de handicap quel que soit l'âge c'est
toujours comme un bébé alors à 42 ans il
faut mettre tous les jours la laver
lui faire son shampoing lui donner son
petit déjeuner l'habiller
il faut faire tout avec elle parce que
autrement elle n'y arrive pas elle a
besoin d'une d'une tierce personne à
côté d'elle tous les jours donc voilà
c'est mon quotidien c'est tous les jours
qu'il faut qu'il faut s'occuper d'elle
quand elle part après la journée ben je
peux faire autre chose sachant que le
soir quand elle rentre mais je dois
toujours m'occuper de cette adulte là
même à 42 ans c'est comme si qu'on a un
bébé je dirais de deux ans ou trois ans
parce que maintenant il y a déjà comme
elle a vieilli donc ça veut dire qu'elle
se dégrade elle a encore davantage
besoin de quelqu'un auprès d'elle
et c'est la journée et la nuit ça se
passe comment c'est pareil il faut aussi
voilà la nuit également si elle se
réveille il faut s'occuper d'elle alors
vous allez me dire quand elle se
réveille qu'est-ce qu'elle fait et bien
il y a des jeux qui sont là à mis à
disposition les jeux se sont les cubes
autrement il y a le laçage parce qu'elle
aime bien faire son laçage elle a un
mouchoir qu'elle plie qu'elle déplie
constamment parce qu'elle a des
tendances autistiques donc elle a besoin
d'une de geste répétitif alors c'est
pour ça qu'elle a toujours un petit
chiffon dans la main pour qu'elle puisse
manipuler donc le soir quand elle se
réveille mais je me mets à côté d'elle
et puis ben on reste un moment ensemble
et après elle se rendort et puis voilà
la nuit passe et le matin ça recommence
donc le quotidien est rythmé mon
quotidien est rythmé avec ma fille je ne
peux pas dire que je fais quelque chose
il faut que je vois elle d'abord et
après ben je fais la suite quoi ça vous
laisse pas beaucoup de temps pour vous
en fait le temps comme je vous dis c'est
limité juste quand elle est dans sa
structure la parce qu'elle part le matin
vers 8h30 elle rentre à 16h le soir donc
là on a le temps de faire ce qu'on a à
faire et quand elle arrive il faut
reprendre en mai jusqu'à ce qu'elle
donne le jusqu'à ce qu'elle prenne son
lit et la nuit si elle se réveille ben
il faut quand même
il faut prendre le relais comme on dit
on ne veut pas la laisser seule parce
qu'elle va faire des bêtises vous voyez
par exemple à la maison on peut pas
laisser des allumettes on peut pas
laisser des couteaux on peut pas laisser
des choses traîner non non c'est trop
dangereux
vigilance constante donc vous avez
bénéficiez vous de du séjour dentaire
qui est un dispositif qui est dans le
répit repos est-ce qu'on peut revenir
sur ce dispositif Stéphanie sur le
dispositif le séjour dentaire donc le
séjour en terre c'est un c'est un séjour
qui qui profite donc aux aidants
effectivement ils peuvent bénéficier de
trois jours de répit donc au village
corail donc où c'est pris en charge à
hauteur de 95% donc par le groupement
c'est vrai qu'il reste à la charge de de
l'aidant on va dire 5% et mais la prise
en charge donc pendant ces trois jours
ils peuvent bénéficier vraiment de
prestations sur le village corail donc
des activités de loisirs et puis pris en
charge le sens où quand ils y vont donc
au village corail ils n'ont pas à faire
cuire à manger c'est vraiment pris en
charge totalement on va dire sur le site
donc ils ont la peau la mère à proximité
ils peuvent vraiment bénéficier de la
structure totalement et pouvoir profiter
profiter on va dire de tous les les
commander prestations qui se trouvent on
va dire proches de du village corail et
justement comme Madame boulevard elle
l'a dit elle elle a profité de ce séjour
donc avec avec sa fille a priori et
c'est vrai que ça permet de pouvoir
aussi peut-être dans le cas de ce séjour
donc de redécouvrir des choses
effectivement qu'on n'a pas qu'on
partage pas forcément à la maison et
c'est vrai que le séjour on a constaté
que le séjour effectivement apporte
beaucoup de choses aux aidants familiaux
et surtout ben sortir de leur quotidien
et de profiter on va dire pleinement de
d'autres moments avec avec leurs proches
on va dire au quotidien et vous donc ça
s'est passé comment vous êtes partis
combien de jours comment ça s'est
organisé vous êtes partis avec qui oui
alors je dirais d'abord un grand merci
au conseil général qui a mis cela en
place alors moi j'ai fait partie de de
la primeur je dirais ça a été fait je
crois en 2012 et dès que ça a commencé
je suis allé au premier séjour là-bas au
VVF vraiment je peux vous dire que ça
s'est très bien passé avec bien sûr mon
idée je suis allé mon mari ma fille et
moi-même on a eu des trois jours
vraiment
merveilleux là-bas parce que d'abord on
était bien accueillis vous savez vous
n'avez pas de parfait à la cuisine vous
arrivez vous avez même votre nom sur la
table et important vous n'avez pas le
couvert à mail vous n'avez pas à penser
ce qu'on va manger le soir est-ce qu'on
va prendre le petit déjeuner le matin
tout était vraiment calé on était on y
est vraiment au petit soin alors je vous
dis vraiment c'était merveilleux on a
passé ben en 2012 on a fait trois jours
en 2013
on a eu également le séjour 2014 pareil
parce que moi tous les ans sur le
renouvelle puisque c'est tellement
intéressant que il faut pas laisser
tomber quoi et le fait de vous retrouver
à la mer avec votre fille ça ça a permis
de de
d'avoir un échange différent de
l'échange que vous avez au quotidien ou
c'est beaucoup plus lourd à gérer parce
que déjà on sort de la maison et vous
arrivez là-bas c'est vraiment comme le
nom l'indique ces jours grands air c'est
vraiment le grand air parce que vous
avez la plage vous avez la mer à la
plage vous avez tout devant vous à
perdre de vue quoi donc ça fait vraiment
un changement et l'enfant quand il se
retrouve aussi ben il est heureux et ce
que je trouve aussi bien c'est que la
bague on rencontre aussi mais d'autres
aidants et ça c'est merveilleux parce
qu'on peut faire des échanges
là je trouve que c'est
d'expérience oui ça peut nous aider en
disant les autres parce que là on voit
que on n'est pas seul on a sans souci
mais on voit un côté aussi il a aussi
donc c'est un partage c'est un essai un
échange vraiment je dis profitable en
tout cas c'est une très bonne initiative
que je salue et que je remercie au nom
de tous les aidants puisque là je suis
sur le plateau là c'est vraiment une
bonne initiative je pense qu'il faut
continuer alors justement Stéphanie
combien de personnes ont bénéficié de ce
dispositif depuis 2012 depuis que le
dispositif a été mise en oeuvre ce sont
plus de 2300 et dents soient 4200 en
couple aidants et des qui ont bénéficié
de ce dispositif et c'est un budget de
plus de 1 million 400.000 euros qui a
été consacré à la mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif depuis 2012 et pour rebondir
2015 le dispositif sera renouvelé à
l'identique avec quelques nouveautés sur
lesquelles nous travaillons et que nous
souhaitons proposer aux aidants pour
pour l'année 2015
les aidants peuvent accéder au
dispositif et pire auto par le biais du
numéro vert qui est le 08 53
002 c'est un numéro gratuit
par le biais de ce numéro donc nous on
procède à un montage de dossiers par
rapport à ses aidants et tout récemment
en octobre 2014 sur le sud on a une
structure appelée maison des aidants et
des aider qui permettent également aux
aidants de se rapprocher de cette
structure pour pouvoir faire des
montages de dossier concernant les
dispositifs dans tous les cas le GIP
permet aux aidants de constituer des
dossiers sans se déplacer c'est vraiment
notre force c'est nous qui allons vers
les aidants
cette émission on peut quand même
souligner que le gpsap a reçu le Prix
territorial d'argent 2014 dans le
domaine des services à la personne pour
son action le répit au repos pouvez-vous
nous dire qui desserne ce prix et
surtout en quoi c'est une vraie
reconnaissance pour le Conseil Général
de la Réunion alors ce prix donc est
décerné par l'Observatoire de
l'innovation de l'action publique
territoriale donc il se trouve à Paris
et puis c'est le président du Sénat qui
préside cette observatoire donc c'est
l'un des prix les plus honorifiques qui
est décerné donc aux actions qui sont
menées par les collectivités
territoriales qui vient récompenser
reconnaître le travail qui a été mené
par le département de La Réunion au
travers du gipsap dans la mise en oeuvre
du dispositif répit repos et nous sommes
tous fiers de d'avoir reçu d'avoir reçu
ce prix qui était donc remis donc à la
présidente du conseil général donc on
est fiable pour pour nous mais pour tous
les aidants puisque c'est une
reconnaissance locale et nationale de
notre dispositif alors je vous remercie
d'avoir échangé avec moi sur 9 7 4 télé
la télé du conseil général un numéro
vert est à la disposition des personnes
qui veulent se renseigner pour
bénéficier du dispositif et connaître un
peu les conditions donc on peut faire
quel numéro alors c'est le 0800 530
002 alors c'est gratuit merci encore à
nos témoins madame boulevard merci à
Stéphanie Vergoz un grand merci
également à Michael Cuvelier qui a
réalisé cette émission à très bientôt
sur 9 7 4 TV